my name is RA Washington and I'm gonna
show you my cleaver scrappy interesting
Tamir rice was murdered some of the
first community meetings you know happen
in this space
this is a touch point of the community
becoming increasingly agitated about
police violence joblessness lack of
stuff for the youth to do at the same
time you gotta worry that the police
make you I don't understand why they
know she was the pocket
it's got a little bit of that vibe
jegging we better go over to the
downtown where the convention is
happening landscape change Senate
putting those rhythm over the lawn
chairs
it's really funny and Republicans are
largely responsible for some of the
policies that led us this way that they
get down a party in our city hopefully
all these businesses making a bunch of
money so we just finished two of my
Cleveland believe I live in that's not
gonna be seen in artsy